To construct this diagram,
you should take the following steps using a UML class model diagram as notation.
First of all, indicate external actors but only one activity.
That is, there's only going to be one class in here and
that's the class of the text browser itself.
Indicate in the external stimuli or events that can affect the text browser.
And indicate how the text browser communicates it's results back to
the external actors, it's percepts.
So you want to take a crack at producing such a, a,
a diagram that lays out the text browsers relationship to the external actors.
>> Okay, so I have I think kind of what are the things that you can
do to the system.
>> Okay, let's, let's start with [COUGH] what are the actors,
the external actors?
>> So for the external actors, I've shown drawn the user using the text browser,
but also I believe we mentioned previously that the operating system is
also an actor, even though you may not think of it visually, like,
see that happening.
>> Okay.
So there's two external actors in here.
The end user and
the operating system which is going to supply the actual file contents.
There's the the classic self which represents the system, okay.
And you also have some events okay.
What events do you have?
>> So, an event that the user would, start with the user,
what the user can do with a text browser, view the text browser,
can move the handle that's in the tray, and then also resize the text browser.
>> So which one of, which ones of those are events?
>> events?
The movement of the handle's an event,
the resizing of the window's also an event.
Viewing's kind of like a continuous process,
there's no kind of instantaneous event that's happening.
>> Well but the system is not doing the viewser, viewing,
the use is doing the viewing, so.
>> Correct. >> That's actually a percept of the system right.
>> Okay. >> It's something that the system provides for the user.
In addition to the actual lines of file,
what else is the system communicating back to the user?
>> We're also communicating back the size of the handle.
Something that we're seeing.
>> That, that says something about the proportion of the file that's visible.
>> Correct.
And we're also communicating back to the user the height of the view port.
>> Okay.
Obviously the the user has control over that height.
And the system is
going to give feedback by showing a view port with different heights on it.
And you mentioned also that the contents, and that's clearly a percept as well.
So we have the height of the viewport, it's contents, the size of the handle,
and the position of the handle on the tray is another percept.
>> Correct. >> Okay, and we have the two events, the resizing event and
the scrolling event.
We have the two external actors and we have the class itself.
Okay, so we can take the informal sketch that you've done, and
we can lay it out using some kind of UML tool into a precise UML diagram that's
got the single rectangle indicating the, the class labeled text browser.
It's got some attributes which include the height,
the the contents that are visible, the handle size, the handle position.
Its got some external actors for the user and the file system.
Its got some events indicating the user what the user can do to
affect the text browser, and I've also put into the image into the diagram some
real mode comments which are the rectangles with the dog eared corners on them.
Note that there are some certain subtleties that haven't included in
here such as how we're going to deal with zero length files and so on.